à l'étranger et coup d'oeil sur le reste
de l'actualité avec le rwanda les
nations unies ont demandé au congo
d'envoyer sur place des casques bleus
pour soutenir leurs missions
d'assistance
hier soir les soldats de l'onu ont dû
renoncer à une évacuation terrestre d'un
millier de réfugiés
en revanche un avion-cargo canadien a pu
décoller de kigali
il y avait à son bord 31 enfants pro
gravement blessé pour être soignés sur
place
leur rapatriement était organisée sur la
france par médecins du monde avec l'aide
des ministères de la santé et de la
coopération
ces enfants sont arrivés tout à l'heure
à paris orly ils seront dans un premier
temps soignées dans différents hôpitaux
français avant d'être recueillis dans
des familles